hello everyone and if I don't see you
tomorrow happy new year everyone as you
all know which one at around 1:00 to
2017 world rapid championship and Jew
engine here one to 2017 world rapid
Championship for women I chose this game
when John is playing against 13 July
things you like won second place here
and it's it's really a great game
between the two of them and the other
reason I chose this game is because it
features a very cool opening the four
Knights game and I also decided to share
one story about that opening but we'll
get to that too engine is the third
highest rated woman in the world after -
and Anna Musa took it's really ashamed
animals who didn't play in this
championship since Juventud also like on
a moose joke last year won this
championship the rapids
without losing a single game I think
it's eight wins and seven rows or it
could be seven wins and a draw is not
not really sure so they're definitely a
deserving title and she's playing
against ting gy who is the current 2017
women's China champion so so let's see
this game I think July has the white
pieces and she plays efore we have E 5
and Knight to f3
we have Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and
Knight to c6 the four Knights game and
this is a why I also chose chose this
game it is exactly in this opening that
Michael Tao in 1954 in Riga won his
first game against the Grandmaster that
the Grandmaster is Yuri Auerbach and I
don't think I've shown any games by Yuri
over but other than that game he played
against Mischa osipov where he kinda let
him win but it's interesting that every
time I speak of your buckets he's
playing against some Misha out there and
in this position top lady for our back
plate in capture some v4 and we have it
Knight to d5
this is the so-called Belgrade gambit
and they say it took your a our back
here like an hour to figure out his next
move after that hour he played night to
be four and four this is like move five
for the next five moves our back also to
another hour and in the end he lost this
game on time so this is a
this is part of the game how Michael Tao
won his first game against a grandmaster
but getting back to this game after
Knight to c6 things Eli goes for Bishop
to b5 this is the so-called Spanish
variation and when June replies with
Bishop to b4 this is the double Spanish
variation we have castles castles and B
3 d6 now Bishop to g5 and now Knight to
e7 aventurine invites a light to capture
on f6 but if you capture after G
captures and f6 you don't really have
anything with white here you just give
up your Bishop prepare this night will
come to g6 f5 will be an idea this night
will be able to pressure age for an f4
in the future so not a lot of not a lot
of progress made here for white so
instead nice to e2 was played
we have c6 Bishop to a4 and Knight to g6
now c3 Bishop to a5 and night to g3 and
h6 now White has to decide what to do
with this Bishop Bishop to e3
we have d5e capture Sun d5 Knight
captures on d5 and a bishop to d2 we
have Bishop to b6 now getting the bishop
to a more useful Square from here he's
eyeing DF to pawn and here things I
think July played d4 and this d4 was was
not really a blunder but a big
inaccuracy better here was something
like Bishop to c2 or rook to e1 but d4
simply doesn't work and when Jim takes
advantage of this by playing Bishop to
g4 now we don't really have a way of
resolving a resolving this tension in
the center if you capture then after
Knight captures on e5 you don't really
have a way to add more protectors of the
knight on f3 the knight is also pinned
it can't move black can always capture
mess up White's pawn structure rook e8
is coming you don't really have a lot of
options here for white so after this
Bishop to g4
why plate h3 but now comes the bishop
captures and f3 given up the bishop
there but this comes with winning upon
so it's not bad
Quinn captors on f3 and E captures on b4
so black just want to pawn if you
recaptured Bishop can always recapture
so you don't really gain the pawn back
and c4 we have Knight to e7 rook F to e
1 and Bishop to c7 now and B for
expanding on the Queen side Knight to e5
this comes with a temple on the Queen
Queen b3 the Queen doesn't really have a
lot of useful useful squares here rook
to b8 preparing b5 and we have F 4 now
attacking the knight on e5 but avenging
simply pushes b5 and now we don't really
have a good move here other than
capturing this night since your Bishop
on e4 is attacked so F captors on e5
would have B captures on a4 and Queen to
d3 went to d3 is with the idea of
blocking the d4 pawn if you capture the
a for pawn instead the neither Knight to
g6 grabbing d5 pawn or the immediate to
d3 is also fine for black and it's it's
an excellent position so after this B
captures on a4 Queen to d3 now blocking
the pawn and we have Knight to g6 now
threatening to win d5 pawn we have E 6
with the idea of if black captures white
can recapture but Queen to b6 now and
this comes with a double attack on the
night and g3 it's only defended once by
the Queen and here you don't really have
a lot of good options Knights the f1 was
played and this is the best move if you
play something like e captures and f7
years this does come with tempo but
after rook captures now Knight to f1
isn't really a good idea
I mean it's you don't really have a move
here anymore for white if you play an
eye to f1 to defend h2 because Queen
Queen to h2 is coming simply rook B to
f8 now the threat is rook captures night
followed by Queen to H 2 and this will
be checkmate because the rook and f8 is
also now guarding the F file
so after g3 preventing Queen from
jumping to h2 simply Knight to e5 what a
temple on the Queen Queen has to move
and now Knight f3 check will pick up the
exchange white is getting crushed here
so after this Queen
be six you don't really have the option
of grabbing the pawn a knight to f1 was
played and now comes Knight to e5 again
you don't really have the luxury of
capturing this you simply have to allow
this pawn to be captured if you play
something like let's say Queen to g3
getting the Queen out of the way
simply Knight captures on c4 and you can
exchange Queens but this is this is a
winning position for black but it might
have been more resilient than what team
Jill I decided to play at least here you
can hope for black to make some in
accuracy or two in the future and maybe
pile up on that but after 95 would have
each captures on f7 again this isn't the
best choice rook captures and we have
Queen to e2 getting the Queen out of the
way Queen to g6 now and we have King to
h1 the threat of course is nice to have
3:14 the king and the rook so King has
to move and here we have Knight to b3
attacking the rook and you can't really
move the rook if you play something like
rook to be 1 to get it out of any
attacks the knight comes to f2 with
check King do you want only move Knight
captures on h3 the G pawn is pinned King
h1 and our rope to f2 there is no
defense against Queen captures and g2
white would you probably have to give up
the Queen or play some some other losing
move so after Knight to d3 g4 was played
simply Knight captures anyone why not
Bishop captures and d3 now would attempt
on the Queen Queen has to move and now
comes Queen to f6 and in this position
Chinese Grand Master tiin July resigned
the game there are too many threats in
this position do engine is threatening
to capture the knighted there is a
double attack on tonight also there is
an attack on the rook on a1 if you you
can't defend both threats you can't move
the bishop for example to protect the
knight again with the rook because the
rook is hanging so you'd have to play
something like rook to d1 get it out of
the way but simply Queen captures an f1
wins brilliantly Queen captures rook
captures and after King moves simply
rook beat to f8 and white white is
without a move
you can't even capture the d3 born
because your Bishop is hanging here on
e1 so after this very nice Queen to f6
move King July resigned the game and
this is a game from round four so very
early in the tournament but already
decided probably the winner of this
event since when June in the end got
first place in the rapid section and
things like that second place and there
was only a half a point difference so so
very intense so yeah like I said it's
very unfortunate that animals took
decided not to play in this championship
not why she didn't decide I mean it's
just a shame that such a great player
doesn't play in the World Championship
since animals also won last year's rapid
section without losing a single game so
it would definitely be a more intense
tournament but maybe she will join - and
follow in the steps of you this blogger
and not not playing the women's section
altogether but we'll see we'll see
there's a whole new year of chess
tournaments in front of us so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Matthew Haines John
Battaglia Miki grammatic of generic
Ortiz and Stephan Moyer for a
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
I really appreciate it and especially
thank you Matt akov you're the person
who contributed on the first day that I
actually allowed contributions to my
channel so thank you a lot
I'm very glad to see that after all
these months you're still enjoying my
content so that's it like I said if I
don't see you happy new year everyone
and I hope you have hope you have a
great time and a great year as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon probably with a game from
the women's section of the world blitz
championship see you soon